[Music]
in mcpeet down news macbeth down
okay submitted by chicken feet a viral
video shows the McDowell's workers
beating the shuffle root customer i saw
this [ __ ]
yo it's a big-ass girl right
she got [ __ ] horrible alright so this
takes place in Las Vegas Heywood good
old Vegas I love Las Vegas I don't know
where that accent came from ready
everyone travels today sobbing Joe
beverage dick no chance how she watch
the titty flop out amazing but I buy
that dude can't even stop her and look
at this look the other workers trying to
help yeah and then she gets attacked
right did you have I'm telling you man
lil chicks have no fear that's why I've
learned damn no fear to all us they
think they give because nobody's ever
punch them in the face that ain't gonna
do she took it like a child
yeah like a child my god dude have you
ever been to Las Vegas
[ __ ] that is satisfying yeah that girl
looks like six five though ha that laid
that worker she looks like she's six
five there it is I forgot what this
video was called there was a [ __ ]
funny eyes callback that girl's butt
cheek looks like a Chinese fortune
cookie
yeah move the cursor away you're not
talking about that [ __ ] looks like a
fortune cookie fortune cookie it's a
hungry hungry hippo just eatin those
shorts right
yeah girls come carefully
I'd like to the dog park now and there's
like teenage chicks walking around like
that with their bubbles hanging up I bet
you're so disappointed and so sad I feel
creepy oh I know it's kind of like wait
a minute
you shouldn't be dressing like you're
ready to [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
uncomfortable and the dads like what can
I do I've been neutered nobody listens
to me anymore you know what I feel like
happened in that video that girl was
talking so much [ __ ] to that girl that
came out I kicked her ass yeah but she
was at the [ __ ] French fryer in the
back so she didn't realize how big she
was this she was like what's the oh [ __ ]
coming up you know that [ __ ] is the
biggest girl I've ever seen in my life
dude yeah see she [ __ ] works for the
Niners dude a hops like a lineman look
at her you see that dude the dude was
like yeah I wanna help but I don't get
my ass beat either that's his girlfriend
that's fighting to get her ass beat no
no the bigger girl he wha
that's her boyfriend dude that girl was
tight because her little bottom legs
didn't move but she was all upper body
dude yes it was wild so her name is
Erica the McDonald's worker and then the
girl getting your ass beat her name is
Sabrina and apparently she's a stripper
so this is what she looks like free ha
ha ha oh I see that's a good angle I've
been watching a lot I used to gram video
strippers never clean their locker room
every knows that it's like always messy
man
so you ever go do a woman's bathroom
it's like saw its blood and there's
everything
ladies are stripping Christine what are
you talking about the locker so what do
we talk about what type of lady are we
talking about because there's two in
your presence let's clap no there isn't
I'm talking about your bathrooms our
NASA all right uh what what bathroom
would you prefer to take a [ __ ] in a
public Mill's bathroom or public
female's bathroom public males neither
male bath you guys have blood coming out
your [ __ ] yeah yeah your name all over
the place I saw dude you guys [ __ ] on
their [ __ ] toilets whose is that who
their [ __ ] we're gentlemen like I said
that just even walking by the bathroom
it smells like [ __ ] no idea what you're
talking about
I've only seen gas station coed
bathrooms that have [ __ ] all over yeah
we gotta clean ourselves or else home
beats us up for making the bathroom so
nasty pilots that's why you get [ __ ] all
over them it's the bathroom it kind of
guy who's like made a living as [ __ ]
let's do a test right now I'm gonna pop
open either one of your trunks and then
one of the guys trunks let's clean up
please cuz your Chong's already messy my
trunks empty but it's full of fur and
mud cuz of dogs cuz you're dirty no I'm
not the dogs are just made of nasty in
there I thought you were gonna be on my
good side this episode but you're not
the worst thing about getting in a fight
now - it's nobody stops fights anymore
they just film it that's true would you
have stopped the fight with the girl
who's eight hundred pounds he looked
like a freezer came to life you know it
looks like a freezer with man
dude she looks like one of the creatures
from rampage with with the rock I've
never stopped fights though unless
they're my friends but I usually like I
like fights so I encourage them and I
never really you encourage fight yeah I
never really stopped to be the Asian
culture yeah yeah yeah I never I never
really stop it unless I feel morally
wrong about it I stop it if it seems
like one person's about to die yeah look
like she's about to die she's so [ __ ]
annoying the person who broke it up
started beating her ass dude that's how
annoying Giada
that's why I didn't feel bad for her and
then she actually threw a milkshake in
the very beginning milk Jonah it looks
like the big girl just came and started
attacking but it's if you look closely
she threw a milkshake at her how dare
you waste that delicious treat again
McDonald's milkshakes are fine
she's so tall she touches the [ __ ]
electronic sign on top Oh
oh yeah she hit her with the train she
tried blocking yourself with the Train
that is dumb big chicks like the beat up
I'm pretty girls yeah that's some
straight-up women's prison [ __ ] orange
is the new black right there why does
that happen all the time I think it's
just bottled up like ten years worth of
bullying and she's just kind of
unleashed she's gonna all the bullying
damn I mean like when chicks don't get
dick they get angry
I mean one's definitely getting dick
well there's not the big girls that's
her boyfriend
I think it might have been the milkshake
that got her pissed that's apparently
Sabrina was talking [ __ ] for a long time
and then that's when finally apparently
she said something about Erica's mom
because in the video she's saying like
yeah don't beat up mom would y'all would
you fight for your mom like if someone
talks [ __ ] about your mom would you go
straight up and start fist just throwing
this is that a woman thing like not my
[ __ ] mama oh you do the [ __ ] thing
I think that's a good thing I don't know
what else is a hood thing is after you
get your ass but you still talk [ __ ]
[ __ ] you up you don't know me yo she's
kind of resilient though cuz she got her
[ __ ] face beat in and she was so like
no I'm winning this [ __ ]
flopped out and that's a good thing dude
you just get your ass beat and you still
have to talk [ __ ] like you won I give it
to it Sabrina got charged with battery
and Erica Sabrina the Samoan man yeah I
wonder how that affected her lap dances
how many people want to get a lap dance
from a stripper with a black eye
that might be a fetish to like a ya beat
up bird kind of I like black eyes and
brown eyes I would have fired I would
have either that means I don't have to
hire security if I have her and she's
worked damn this dough I just be scared
dude so your fires are you sure about
that all she got was that good tiny
little scratch on her knuckles because
she was over tooth
Sabrina's tooth yeah so she was like
nothing happened to me is she Polynesian
so you say you know what's so funny is
you go to McDonald's and like you go to
restaurants now and they always put the
calories it's like I don't need that I
just look at the staff I know how
healthy the food is by how the staff
looks McDonald's is [ __ ] right do they
put calories at fast-food restaurants
it's the law oh I forgot how many like
how depending on how big your food
company is you have to put the calories
on there so even lnl has it not to where
you all right like when I walk into a
fast-food restaurant though that she
doesn't even matter it's like duh it's a
thousand for a hamburger that's what
happened when I went to when they
enacted that law every Chevys had it Pat
it right and I didn't realize either I
ate my meal it was the Chevy's like
burger the fries and the drink and the
whole meal is like 3200 calories yeah
did it make you change your mind though
no I didn't get a shake but still like I
just I was just glad to know like it's
32 it doesn't stop me I just call oh
[ __ ] I guess that's much this bro alone
was like 1,600 and then then it was the
fries and the drinks and appetizers that
we had yeah so and that's like typical
what we eat at Chevy's or whatever right
it was just a set meal Chevy's Oh chef
E's is like
Chili's Chili's like a diner oh yeah so
we have we have that out in Sacramento
and so uh that [ __ ] was wild dude like I
didn't know it's crazy
3200 isn't that like the recommended
calorie was for a day like mm like a
week on average its average is 2,000
calories a day by 2200 a day for like
that average person yeah walk 3200 that
was dinner so I had two meals before
then I didn't realize you don't know
these type of things I am addicted to
McDonald's ice cream oh it's so good
dude it's got crack in it or something
cuz I gotta have it every day you really
every day I go to McDonald's and the
shady [ __ ] I like this
it's adults the way to go I'm addicted
to everything McDonald's chick-fil-a
I got you a chicken sandwich fish fillet
cheeseburger and a quarter pounder I get
Mac sauce the Big Mac sauce put an N
there Chicken McNuggets a pile is still
like ever since they - you know no have
you tried the taro pie in Hawaii they
got the it's the it's the purple one I
like the rice in the in Hawaii the
McDonald's rice the wackest thing you've
ever said to describe oh my god thank
you for adding nothing to this
conversation I like the rice it's really
good thank you yeah I like the Icelandic
McDonald is greater regional McDonald's
is pretty dope because they have that
like different item for wherever you're
at I don't know if there's anything in
the south or east coast yeah is there
anything different nah not on Elise no I
think it's like I got to get you guys
those uh big they sent me a [ __ ] stack
of nut been saying that I know you
haven't given it yeah I they tweeted at
me and they gave me a [ __ ] stack of
that [ __ ] no [ __ ] about the movie yeah
delicious were you bird King guy riders
no he's just bitter because they don't
recognize him and he loves them a lot
like the most we got me they tweet out
our friend and then like I used to be
with them like [ __ ] them because they
didn't give me any attention but
certainly out of nowhere yeah me a
letter and all that stuff
if [ __ ] them yeah so McDonald's
recognize you the creepy clown yep
that's he shaved [ __ ] when they want to
be my friend now and they sent me a they
wrote a handwritten letter
[Music]
[Music]